or do you ever see people around you
that make the mistake of thinking that
money is actual goal and then they maybe
got into it aiming to achieve Freedom or
these other things security but then
they are just so caught up in moving
that goal post that they forget
kind of the end goal all the time it
sometimes becomes an obsession and it's
a it's an obsession and it also they can
do it for
um things like
um status
um or whatever and status is really an
insecurity in other words it's trying to
get the approval for others and so on
and so
um rather than ah I love it whatever the
thing is I love it like for me I love
nature right there doesn't cost me
anything really and when I go fit into
it I think it's the greatest luxury and
so on so you must not lose sight of what
it is and people get hung up on these
things they lose sight because of other
the associations and even the society
values things you look around and
everybody's valuing this thing and then
they get hung up because they think it
must be of value you must know your
nature and you must feel it and and and
and know what you think what you feel